so when my husband and I moved to  Sudbury 22 years ago and we just fell in  love with the area and we wanted to put  something back into it what we do need  is we need a mix of experience and age  groups there are very very few that are  young and working it is difficult when  you're working to combine it because it  is hard work and you have to attend the  meetings and you take calls from your  residents and emails so it is  challenging if you're working but we do  definitely need that mix of Ages  experiences skill base so if you want to  be a counselor come forward put your  name down talk to other counselors talk  to officers see if it's for you and if  it is put your name forward for next  year  foreign  [Music]